so you boys been up to anything
interesting recently i mean we're
currently back in lockdown aren't we so
we haven't really been able to do much
not really
japanese government's pretty useful well
i mean yeah but i said emergency
statement restaurants please close at
eight
so you can still travel and do whatever
you want but you know
it's not an enforced lockdown in japan
it's always a suggestion yeah it's just
it's
a suggestion in japan people listen yeah
yeah
that was [ __ ] crazy i think like uh
where was it it was like
it was because usually after we finish
recording a podcast we go and have
dinner and stuff like that yeah
and i think we were at uh like one of
the restaurants nearby and they were
playing like news footage
and shinjuku is empty yes there was a
[ __ ] shot of shinjuku station
zero people in front of it which is like
crazy because shinjuku station if you
guys don't know is like
literally the most busy station i think
in the world isn't it yeah yeah it is
yeah it is at least in japan no it's the
world i think
really that doesn't surprise me shinjuku
station i i die a little inside whenever
someone whenever a friend comes to japan
and i ask where to meet and they say
yeah okay
meeting at shinjuku station is
impossible but like navigating it
isn't so bad no i [ __ ] hate it i
think ikebukuro is worse than navigating
no
i know what are you on because when you
try and get to like the other like the
subway lines
you're like for some reason station
literally has like 30 exits yeah dude
has maybe like 10. like depending on
which exit you come out of
shinjuku like it tells you to go on the
other side of the station
and you would think walking in a
straight line would work no you can't
walk in a straight line in shinjuku
because you've got to pass
depending on where you're on the station
you've got to pass through like 10
different gates at least with igbo
station i always if someone's just like
meet at this gate that i don't know
where the [ __ ] it is then i'll just go
out of the regular gate and i can at
least walk around the station yeah but
if you try and do that with shinjuku
station you're [ __ ]
if you ever come to japan and you're
gonna meet anyone here
and you're staying you and you're
staying near shinjuku never say you're
gonna
meet at shinjuku station it is a lie
okay
it's saying you're gonna meet at
shinjuku station it's like saying you're
gonna meet
somewhere in like times square or
something like that it's a
massive area and station doesn't do no
it's not even that it's like saying like
i'll meet you in new york
yeah it's like all right cool you just
pick a place
outside of the station and then yeah
send them the google yeah but you could
do that with
any other station would be way easy to
get out of i guess yeah because i i
remember
i i i met jeff here mother's basement at
shinjuku station and
as soon as he said it i was like oh here
we go gotta gotta find
it's basically finding where's wally
with your mates and you know with jeff
it shouldn't be hard because he's
[ __ ] massive right and he says and
he i i ask him where he is and he goes
oh i'm uh
near this place i think it's it looks
like there's a big camera nearby i'm
like
cool eight it's like yeah it's like cool
so so i go to like
the nearest big camera and so big camera
is like this huge department store
um it's like an electronic store
basically
um so i go to the west
shinjuku big camera right and then i
send him the message
and i'm just like okay i'm outside big
camera and he goes i don't see you and i
go
[ __ ] it was that at that point i knew
ticks off one [ __ ] up and i and i
tell him just to send me the google map
coordinates and he's on the other side
of the [ __ ] station he's like
shinjuku west
like google maps it's so much easier
you can just literally meet at like
[ __ ] one station overview because
some of the stations [ __ ] lie
with how to get places like ikebukuro as
well has like an east-west
exit or something no dude [ __ ]
shinjuku is like has like
seven westerns it has an east west exit
yeah yeah that doesn't no no no no no no
it doesn't even like shinjuku doesn't
even have an east west exit i think
shinjuku has like
an east-west exit and a new east-west
exit
that's how many exits there are in
shinjuku that they've literally run out
of directions
to name the exits i missed the train
stations in wales where it's just
a platform right that was it that was
the whole station
maybe a vending machine if you were like
honestly like what i usually do
i've done this with a few people and
it's actually proven to be effective is
that instead of meeting in shinjuku you
meet one station down on yamanote which
is yoyogi
because walking because walking to your
yogi like from
shinjuku is the exact same time that it
would take to actually get out of
shinjuku station it is because walking
from one side
of the station to another depending on
where you are could take up to 15 to 20
exactly
whereas like yogi only has two exits
very straightforward nah bro
what do you mean i'm doing what you love
to do best with just min maxing myself
okay what is the optimal strategy right
google has this thing now where it tells
you which cart to get on
so it tells you which train car to get
on for the smoothest and quickest exit
and 95 of the time it's spot on just do
that
i'll see a trick question though there
is no smooth exit or shinjuku there is
there is never i have legit like i i
always feel shinjuku right and obviously
i'm always using why would you do that
because i need to and i listen to what
google my my god google tells me
you know every time and it bang on it's
like go this exit go up the first
set of stairs you see every single time
it's basically right
you think someone who just come to came
to japan will like know
which direction of shinjuku and which
exit there are i don't even know which
exit i get out of
i i mean it works for me i just listen
to what the pc the mo
the pc master race tells me if the
computers tell me to go somewhere i go
where the computer's
okay connoisseurs [ __ ] the first time
you come to japan don't do that no no
because you won't know how to do it
find where you want to go when you go to
the station there'll be numbers on the
floor
just pick the number what the google
tells you to go on
and then do it trust me shinjuku you all
get lost
navigating the station yeah don't don't
trust the station signs because
they'll be like oh yeah if you're on the
platform be like the exits
this way what if you don't trust the
station that's all i've got because
because when you go to shinjuku and you
follow google maps right google maps
says
take the west exit out of shinjuku and
then you go you go to you go out your
trailer
you go see the signs and there is
literally every exit
but the exit that it says on google maps
right you've made the
mistake you're looking at the signs
right the signs what is there to look at
otherwise the signs all they do is
deceive you they
they make you second guess right don't
listen to the system
so full of [ __ ] listen to what google
says 100 right because
thing is right you'll be on the platform
right and there'll be like eight sets of
stairs that you can take
and there'll be an hour this is like
this way this is the way to where you
want to go
and sometimes it's like the most
unoptimized way to get out of the like
to
out of the station or go to the line
that you want to go right and there's a
bunch of stairs it sometimes isn't clear
which stairs to get
it's a mess right if google tells you to
get off at a cart
go immediately to the nearest set of
stairs that you see
i guarantee it'll work and just go out
the exit that you see closest it'll
always work
google knows don't listen to the signs
they're a [ __ ] lie
done try it boys you'll see i don't know
man i
it's i think i'll just avoid getting off
of shinjuku i just i just feel like not
going through shinjuku
is just the optimal strap that's like
saying like
i'm just i want to fly out of the
country without an airport it's like
if you're going to go to japan you're
going to be going through shinjuku yeah
but like i'd rather meet like somewhere
far away from the actual station get me
out of this place
somewhere anywhere near the station yeah
because it's just
extra it's just extra stress you're
adding on to your community if you let
the
ai do it for you i don't know because
it i have tried following the ai and
google maps isn't perfect
that's pretty good is this why is this
why you hate ikebukuro
more because the air
[Music]
[Music]
the way it's been laid out like shinjuku
i get it it makes sense no it doesn't no
it's but the the
thing i'll say about ikebukuro is that
the science makes sense yeah
you can see the size of the thing is
that when i follow a sign to an exit it
actually takes me to the [ __ ] exit
yeah
like because i like putting my trust in
my own sense of direction right
so if i'm in a place like ikebukuro i
can trust that
wherever i am i can find the right way
out i just follow the signs
i just you know follow the signs i want
the optimal not the right way
with with shinjuku i'm if you literally
have to put your trust
in an ai machine to tell you the right
direction
then it is just a poorly planned system
exactly you know
i mean hey it works though i get where i
need to get to
no problem well we'll say that this is
such a
i wonder people watching this you've
never been to japan like what the [ __ ]
is this problem
yeah yeah uh if you've never been to
japan don't listen to connor yeah
listen anywhere outside of shinjuku
trunks listen to the white guy
yeah would you trust the white guy
listen listen to me the white guy
trust me i find life hacks where they
don't exist